[Music]
christopher wilson is a royal biographer
and commentator he joins me live in the
studio thanks very much indeed for for
coming in and clearly we will talk about
her legacy in a moment but i i
understand that you know her quite well
and have met on a number of occasions
and i wonder if you could give your
personal record i don't think that any
writer could ever claim to know uh the
queen intimately but i saw her on many
occasions and uh there's one particular
uh incident which summed her up for me
and it was probably when she was in the
late 80s and she uh had gone
on what was just another routine job she
was
at a party on
a uh cruise ship
many tables of people i sat almost as
place as i am to you
and
i could see her face
throughout the whole this rather very
lengthy lunch
and it never once wavered she never once
for one second looked as though she was
doing anything other than having the
time of her life and yet for her it was
just another job and that i think sums
her up she put her everything into a job
no matter how boring however dull it was
she wanted to show people that she was
having a great time and that they were
giving her that great time and that's
extraordinary to be able to sustain that
for for 70 years absolutely and i think
that she refined the act greatly as time
went on uh well as you would expect you
know she got better and better at it and
she knew when to put her foot on the
pedal and she knew when to take it off
the pedal again in terms of publicity
whether she should be seen a great deal
or perhaps seen less
and in terms of her legacy what how
would you describe queen elizabeth ii
well
without question i think she is the
greatest monarch that
great britain has ever had
um
not only has she uh reigned longer than
anybody else but
she has
been more places she's shaken more hands
she's been seen all over the world she's
gone to places that no other monarch has
ever done
she
has been on magazines television and her
image
over 70 years has
made itself known to
millions billions of people across the
globe
and
i think because she's a benign presence
she is not a challenging presence she
doesn't have to be a politician
who is trying to prove something she is
just who she is and that's how
she managed to keep that act going for
so long
and she has i suppose in some ways
maintain what you know which is a
strange system not many countries in
europe all around the world have have a
system with a constitutional monarchy
what do you think the future of the
monarchy is without queen elizabeth well
the the curious thing about her was it
didn't it looks like she didn't actually
change but she changed a great deal and
for example if you look at her clothes
um they became more modern as time went
on she
[Music]
got the aura of the age if you like her
and she knew
um
very much to inch forward very slowly
without appearing to do so i think that
whoever well who we know who is coming
next uh may find it hard to
have such a a subtle play
we know that it's king charles iii is
going to be the title don't we
i mean how will he follow
what you know all these leaders and you
and many commentators have been saying
an incredible incredible act from the
from the queen well it's going to be
very difficult for him and of course
what he's going to have to do is take
his foot off the pedal he's got to
learn not to interfere with politics uh
the spider
the spider handwriting memos which he
sent to
cabinet ministers have to cease if he is
to maintain that authority as an
independent figure
which is above and beyond politics
that's what the great success of the
queen's reign was that she never once
interfered politically and uh i think
prince charles uh
with his heart very much in the right
place uh has tried to interfere and i
think it's just going to learn not to do
it and in terms of the royal family
itself clearly they've not had the
easiest of times recently and this is a
personal
point of mourning for them but how do
you think they'll react as a family do
you think they'll come together after
this or do you think that the fractures
will continue to be there
i think that's possibly the first
challenge which king charles will face
uh he has got to either knock heads
together or talk to people and try to
bring um a sense of unity back to this
fractured
uh royal family and
we cannot deny the fact that in the last
couple of years as the queen has ailed
uh that we have seen the wheels slightly
falling off the royal train
christopher wilson thank you very much
indeed coming to talk to us thank you
reminder now the top story